there you go Magnus Carlsen whoa whoa
okay take my espresso right now hmm
here we go magnus carlsen the world
champion has just registered for the
style tuesday if I recall correctly it's
his second time ever joining this event
and he's a late entrant I mean he's
still on time but I was not expected at
I can assure you so we are in for a
treat over here title Tuesday May 2017
ten rounds of blitz three minutes plus
two second increment they're playing for
prizes but I'll tell you most
grandmasters most professional players
they play for the glory
blitz is the most enjoyable format for a
lot of professional players the
adrenaline the variables there's more
risk
it's just what we live for so that's
going to be good that is going to be
good let me set up screen here but you
guys tell me what you think is going to
win naca or Carlsen look it's gonna
they're both
maybe consider the two best players in
the world by their peers number one and
number two it depends on who you ask
online is a little bit different
although Magnus did beat Hikaru last
year in the blitz battles but yeah we
have Magnus crossing in the field today
and well I think we're gonna have to
follow him in the first round so if let
me follow Magnus follows kuru and we'll
see a third one some other notable names
Sergei Grigoryants I believe he's twenty
cards tomorrow
Benjamin box member of the Dutch
national team Edward Seaga number one
Venezuelan Alan P show Argentinian
national team the games have started
here title Tuesday April
- sorry May 2017 and we have Magnus
Carlsen playing board one
sometimes we see upsets on board one so
I wouldn't I do hope some drama happens
early on now Camaro negative played each
other many times but this is a huge
event they're not going to play each
other unless they win four five six
games in a row and even a couple title
Tuesday's ago Nakamura lost the very
first round so he's going to have to be
a bit more stable than he sometimes is
in order to get paired with Magnus for
those who don't know Magnus was in
California yesterday I believe for a
summit some sort of conference summit
Danny wrench was also there so I think
Magnus was playing from the US he's
going for his London system easy to play
easy get up on the clock not a lot of
risk and he just knows it very well
so what getting ready to trade off the
dark-squared bishop
he's up like at some point the chief f3
keep kicking the knight out of the e4
square and just claiming pleasant
position due to this bishop on PA which
is locked in so Bishop h2 the night
might be going to add four as well if
black does one trade all those Bishop
G's make it's like I'll just keep my
Bishop and I had a fantastic diagnose so
black decides to oppose it now but these
positions are slightly better for white
and not not positioning one find
yourself in against Magnus he also plays
the Stonewall himself so he's very
familiar with these structures from both
sides but I would say the Stonewall is
an opening that requires a lot of care
and it's not recommended for most levels
playing with his bishop on CA
so bark is delaying the knight to f6
move which looks natural because he
doesn't want wait to play 95 what's
preparing the play 95 as soon as that
square becomes available
Queen a3 now looks nice
then he does it Magnus is up 45 seconds
and this is a really really nice
position just a pleasant Pleasant edge
on board - we have Laurence Trent with
whiting in saqqara Nakamura
so already you know a battle of
well-known people players on Lawrence is
more of a commentator but he's a very
dangerous blitz blaring in zone right
I've played in many times and he scores
a lot of upsets looks like it was an
exchange Spanish or some sort of
position what blocks got the two bishops
looks very comfortable for a good key
card but we're going to focus on one
game at a time I first unless something
crazy happens and here we have Magnus
playing a clean 'less middle game with
more space with better pieces
95 and what's getting ready to say look
you're not developing your bishop I'm
going to open up the position I believe
in development and oh I think you might
take on you for here and play against
this isolate upon this pawn is
permanently bad that means is vicious is
that this is getting worse and worse
this is getting close to being just
completely lost once white recoups the
spawn b4 is going to fall and again this
Bishop is not developing any time soon
so I would be surprised to see a bunch
of 9 to 3 Knight takes e4 everything is
good your Magnus was going to win this
he was even views of sweet dude win this
you guys never have chest rims
yeah 1984 and black has the worst bone
structure worst pieces and a far worse
position on the clock
nothing changes you probably goodbye 93
wings pawn the bishop on see it is still
missing this Siobhan see it is still
missing and you can't be playing down a
piece against the world champion you
need everything active so this is going
to this is going to go downhill pretty
quickly you really see the weakness of
these funds right now the camp moves are
just available to be picked off they
don't contribute to blacks position at
all mm-hmm and now he's threatening
worked 86 of bicha takes c6 because the
back rake is weak which means black has
to take back with the pawn which only
makes it worse
this is this is brutal there's no other
way to put this the pawns this is
something some of some of the worst
pawns you'll deliver see now White has
the outside path spawn he's not picking
this pawn off yet because he's got
background threats you starting to work
takes t7 and Ruby it made again but look
at the time 22 seconds of 2:18 brutal
and he's also talking with b7 and the
bishop is Ben rook d7 is going to be on
the board Magnus Carlsen takes round one
as soon as he defends his knight 92 or
94 anything yeah I expect a resignation
in a couple of moves although if you're
playing negatives you might not want to
resign just to say you lasted a bit
longer
there's a check on b8 and that's a free
bishop or that works as well
Magnus wins let's go to Lauren's turn
the EMC car and Hikaru is down upon as I
said Nakamura has lost in round one
before recently he struggled to be
consistent and I'll do this and he is
down upon her he's up a minute and 20
seconds but there's increment three
minutes opposed to second increment and
Laurens Trent is a pretty dangerous
bullet player as well so even though
he's low on time is very comfortable
this is a lost position for Hikaru
Nakamura
how he's going to pull this out of the
bag down upon and without ways to mess
up the position there's only rooks or
something move it in one way they're
easy to I dissipate you need to
calculate and this should be a standard
win for for white this extra pass pawn
and its king supporting it this is a
loss position for Takara Nakamura and
you guys are hoping for an aqua miracles
and match this tournament you're gonna
be cheering for Nakamoto pull something
out here which I don't know where and
how he's going to do it he does against
me all the time I don't know where it's
coming from though you can play this
fast as you want there's two second
increments and this and as you see black
is slowly getting pushed up King to
rooks and upon pushing to rocks back I
mean that's a huge material deficit on
the Kings side
Nakamura announced playing rock against
Queen but unfortunately this is not a
fortress for many different reasons
too many pawns on the board White's King
is too active and was made all their
nakamura checkmated in round one by
Lawrence Trent as I said in the
beginning he's capable scoring upset
splitting into many times he does it
here and there goes the dream of a
Carlson Nakamura modulus Carlson starts
dropping points big upset already Wow I
mean that was a queen winner - that was
you know that wasn't a mouse lip or
blunder that was a clean win it seems
from I mean soon we start following
alright so as we recover from that
result other games going on who are we
going to follow we're going to follow my
friend Benjamin Bloch from the
Netherlands he is playing where the
player names one second he's playing
black here and he's got a bishop against
Knight which works on the board in an
open position got a favor the bishop
because it is open it is an endgame and
bishops are generally stronger but the
other problem with the swaying factor
here is the upside pass pawn outside
passed pawn for white is actually very
very fast and he's going to just slowly
kick away this bishop so that changes
things that changes things a lot this is
not looking good for black but one thing
he might try is sacrificing my official
flip on and trying to play trying to
play on the King side down the piece but
with drawing possibilities because we're
Canadians rook is a draw so still some
opportunity here to hold it uh-huh you
want to get the pawns off the board you
can take this you can take this pawn yes
you can and now I've lost this position
before because nicer extremely tricky in
blitz
but objectively speaking it's one of the
easier and games to hold a rook and
Knight against rook it's much easier to
hold that rook and Bishop against rook
so in the middle round 1 of title
Tuesday May 2017 edition and make a
scroll since playing that's all you know
he hardly he's got a busy schedule and a
surprise appearance and it's already
paying off because number two seed in
the tournament
Hikaru Nakamura lost round one which
puts them as a huge betting favor and
they repeated here which I mean it's a
fair result but I think you might as
well play on his white knights are very
tricky in time scrambles but ok
Laurita player plays it safe I could
resolve nonetheless what else is going
on this one so it takes it that here we
go this is a game a Cobian playing back
he's just won on time I gained Dutch I
am so that game is over the games just
winding down now some other notable
participant of the tournament see yes Oh
Coco bean is there quite a few French
grandmasters as normal I see new key fan
favorite on the website he wanted game
I see GM Joey another fan favorite from
the Philippines were Helio Antonio play
and he rarely plays in these so
Philippines represents over there who
else they were just waiting for the last
couple of games to finish let me put one
up here's another website David Jakov
Norwood's here playing white I believe
and this might be headed for draw Oh
what was that
what was that move so both sides are
going to Queen and white will have a
pawn for the bishop oh boy this should
be a well now this is just a draw I'm
not sure why he gave up his bishop for
that it should be it is a strange move
there's no other way to put it
this should be it your Bishop is worth
more than a pawn no no that's that's a
strange move but Lee still ensures the
draw just that block was better Queen
and Bishop against Queen upon one side
you know one is going to be the queen
and issue
to go to King's and all the games are
done round two has started immediately
and we have Iceland against Norway on
board one I think this is helgi Olufsen
it is how he awesome a longtime member
of the Icelandic national team I think
he's busy the closest is he still play
sometimes he's been a grandmaster for
decades I've played a multiple time
still quite sharp plays a lot of looks
and he's playing white against Magnus so
we had a Scandinavian battle and round
two over here
I imagine the players have probably
played each other over the board at some
point
Magnus goes for a six this is a recent
trend it's not caught on for the most
part but some strong players have been
playing it it's not the prettiest move
let's put it that way you often end up
weakening your squares considerably when
you play c6 but it's been scoring okay
so this round we Zeppelin will be
following he car most likely because
he's no longer on board too and a lot to
wait for him to catch up he's got a hill
to climb but if there's something who
can do it it's him it's ten rounds and
the winning score is usually nine points
or less so the margin of error
he's still within the margin of error
that loss has not knocked him out of any
sort of spot yet with two losses and
you're struggling so white is going for
just a classic I mean this is like a
Carlsbad structure just the classic
minority attack over here and we'll see
how Magnus places his block this is a
very very classical position Oh a three
and it's not very Ricky for white at all
so we'll see how Magnus mixes it up
that's why he's spending a lot more time
than his first round and he plays b5
okay so he's ready to lock everything
down he wants to play a 5 next move you
want to game up on this d4 pawn and he
also might have ideas at some point of
sticking a knight on c4 just at some
point I think a5 is his immediate idea
and he's done it he's done it and I
wouldn't be surprised to see 96 94
follow up looking good for black this
pollen t6 could be weak but we have to
assess it in the current moment and I
don't see how white actually attacks it
why doesn't that get heat he's allowed
to play that move because the black gets
at this Knight to c4 then the c6 phone
is not accessible to white and then it's
sulphide
so g4 and you want to play g5 and
question this knight on f6 my mistakes
on before first so it also has a threat
and now he's going to decide comply
Bishop e6 Bishop g6 that's about it only
two moves g5 maybe what's wrong the g5
this night has to go to e4 which is not
what I want to do as block helgi Olufsen
playing very well so far seasick is not
going to fall c6 is hanging this should
be well this is double edge but at first
glance it looks okay for black you win
this e6 pawn you lose the g5 pawn is
that on the board no that was my guess
remember if you guys follow the games
alive interface you can make moves
before they do it and if you get it
right there's a little game and I guess
we'll move that tells you at the end of
the game which player anticipated most
moves predict the most correct moves so
this is on the board it is on the board
so um it's double edge now so without
the edge fun black might have ideas
playing Knight f6 we acknowledge for get
some play against White's King side now
Bishop h3 is the threat interesting
specialty 5
no sir efficiently 6 not probably
playable or it's not desired White's
putting up some stubborn resistance
now what happens after bicha bicha teas
done digitation sure he has that's
that's what I thought was a threat but I
I think what white maybe thought was
after cheese free you can take on f1 and
then white can take on d7 threatening of
Queen takes outside no Queen takes f7 is
in checkmate so things are heating up
here see what the players do magnet is
one for checkmate white is going for
pawn structure pawn structure being
favorable in any game is because white
pawns around the dark squares block is a
very weak d5 pawn before sort of loose
especially an endgame so and then game
this will be good for what Magnus has
recognized that in he's he's going for
his attacking right now and I have to
say I completely agree with his train of
thought I needed to say when following
Magnus he just he just does the right
things
yeah Magnus does not want to go into
endgame he wants to finish his older
phone in the middle game over here he's
up 30 seconds on time
he's got tactical shots in the position
and he's definitely banking on that but
he hasn't acted on sailing so I
definitely really do favor boxing I
should have initiative this is worth
quite a bit in blitz I mean you have 30
seconds and you got you there's too many
pieces on the board if you're playing
white here you've got it somehow get
trades going now F now you can take on
g3 and III is hanging no a lot of simple
and well you've got to get heavy pieces
off the board with so many pieces on the
board no time that is a recipe for
disaster you're going to blunder at some
point there's too much to calculate you
simply can't calculate it all and
something gotta get so magnets now that
takes e4 he's got Queen h6 check K he's
got a toxic everywhere okay two might be
close to winning and now Knight g4 check
the bishop is pinned that looks winning
94 check and Knight takes III Oh even
nicer Queen h5 game over I expect a
resignation Wow a very very nice win by
the world champion slow pressure without
a lot of risk and just outplayed his
opponent very comfortably in the middle
game there so Carlsen moves it sorta too
long way to go but he's doing what he's
supposed to do and we're going to move
on to another board you're actually a
challenger wins on one of the top boards
as well he's higher rated 2755 boots he
knows situated too let's check some
other games here we have dutch champion
jordan van forest playing a Hungarian
Grandmaster both pretty evenly rated I'm
guessing this is actually I can't guess
there's a lot of Hungarian grandmasters
hungries one of the strongest chess
countries in the world some people don't
know that
I mean they know the four resistors but
it's just even besides the four
resistors they have one of the top five
countries I would say well in terms of
the strength of their top 10 players
this could be anyone
but black how do you evaluate Queen and
games of the past pawns
both sides have taught spawns here so a
very advanced past pawns
so once you go past the past once you go
past that who has more material and why
does more material so this definitely
looks good for white I think both sides
are going to Queen and why it's going to
be up material so black black starting
to avoid that which is correct but I
mean first you can take this one you
have at least to draw there's no shelter
for blacks King so you can at least take
d5 and then decide absence but if you
want to play for more
the reason black didn't go into didn't
push his fun and try to block white
fondant yeah because both sides Queen
you both lose the Queen and then why it
would just be up to pawns in the
resulting endgame
so what black did was the only try I
don't see a way to stop block from
Queenie which means this is headed to a
draw white in spending time is down to
ten seconds he's trying to find a way
okay Queen h5 check King here Queen this
is gonna be a two Queen position but I'm
going to be cleaning with check but I
don't understand this decision by the
enforce Queen e1 then Queen e8 then King
C to check Oh King up still there's no
checks that's the amazing combat that's
that's very nice so Queen e1 Queenie
eight if King seat or anywhere my king
on f2 actually cannot be checked my
phone on e3 does a great job of
sheltering from a7 so that force was
going to Queen here he's gonna be a
three pawns and he's calculated that his
King is actually safe wait what am I
missing something I'm asking I think I'm
missing something
Queen here what he's just blundered or
something what the heck is this
lost my head I just lost my earbuds I'm
I don't understand what has happened
Oh King aids - you guys are right
yeah I knew I miss something the time
scramble i i i knew i missed something
because Jordan is strong enough that
he's going to find it so I was wrong
about that I was trying to figure out
why he played for win so I assumed he
had seen it but after cleanup - sorry
after Queen here there's just simply
King a - I was looking at these tumors
this is this wins check
[Music]
okay I'm not sure about that there's a
lot to calculate they're not entirely
sure if this is waiting for so I can
always block with clean f1 I don't know
I don't know why didn't he do but anyhow
they had no time so very easy to sit in
the chair
yeah I'm sorry I guess somebody's doing
construction that that doesn't happen
too much at 4:30 p.m. the continues I
might have to complain the problem is I
can't really complain usually ok this
game is finishing problems I can't
really complain easily because I'm
pretty I'm a pretty loud person
especially when I do split games or
sometimes throw things so if I complain
about noise people might complain about
me because sometimes I'm putting on
techno or authoritative so that's that's
the problem that's the problem
too many ragequit that I've done alright
the current standings I'm going to bring
them up after two rounds will bring up
the standings right now a huge group
with 22 as you can see world champion
Magnus Carlsen that I mean he's a 200
point rating favorite but if I recall
the last time you played one of these
events he did lose the game to the field
so it's definitely possible splits after
all
but you had many players onto it to some
well-known names there such as Torres a
guy but for the most part we're going to
see call simply players he's never
really played before which should be
exciting
[Music]
[Music]
all right so round three is about to
begin
we have Carlson playing right here
against Leonardo Tristan from Cordoba
Argentina now that's not me you can see
pretty fine that is not me making noises
but it says if it continues I'll have to
switch to a headset now I turn my
microphone down a little bit during the
construction so Carlson goes for a for
this game is going for an open position
so a little bit of a different strategy
compared to round one it's not going for
slang knees one it's going for an open
position although it already looks good
for looks good for white it is that yeah
somebody's using a drill so what I
expect here at some point is probably f3
Queen d2 and queenside castle option sod
castling should give us a pretty
exciting game White has more space White
has nice little bind restricting blacks
Center here you can really play d5
easily and gain fight back so I mean
it's definitely preferable for for white
we'll see the super black down here um
it kind of has a Philidor pawn structure
c7 and d6
so this is your Bishop e3 oh I didn't
need to guess that this is the current
position 95 probably a Bishop e2 is
safer he's done it because he 5 c4 would
have been annoying oh it was incorrect
yeah you guys can do guess the move it's
very fun by the way now Kumar did win
round two so it's back to 50%
i shouldn't've active determined just
started but better than zero and he goes
for the kingside castle it's a safer
choice after a six because you know
black was getting ready to
counter-attack the benefit of this is a
mega stefank versus chances in a slow
positional game so I'm expecting was
like rook a d1 h3 at some point in order
to play at 4 and now d6 is very weak you
don't get none on this sister you don't
you can't do this now rugby 196 is
critically weak what's going on here
this is looking good for white because
black just created a bunch of weaknesses
you can take and play 91
I know d6 is a problem there's also
Bishop takes e5 of 98 distance this is a
problem already this is already looking
very pleasant for Wyatt there's too many
pawn weaknesses you can't keep the world
champion easy positional targets like
that
so I definitely like this for white I
don't know how you defend d6 you're not
probably going to defend these six
you're going to try to play around it
but you're stuck with it either way
a long think by block here but position
just looks bad I mean I can always play
vehicles for quick Queen b6 you can take
here you can also just play b3 b6 it is
a long-term problem so no rush in
picking it up but this is a big edge for
Magnus you can also consider 92 even not
sure the Queen wants to go sailing far
away and you've gone 92 with the idea
that after Queen takes b2 I'll probably
play would be one Queen a3 and Queen
takes d6 to the queen is simply offside
just offside it's just misplace this
this is getting worse and worse for
black because he's still taking time he
needs to recognize this position was
value needs to play a bit quicker you
need to try to use those bishops to
create dynamic counter play because the
momentum of the game is not in his favor
56 I like this move block is preparing
the plate rook b8 depending upon and
then playing d5 and opening up the
position for the bishop so negative does
have something to chew on right what do
you do about that
so b3 expects capture here and then work
the okay rook e8 first that also makes
sense data for stopping d5 that's
critical
cannot allow black to open up the
position again those d6 d6 is it's going
to be long-term so in the meantime I
think if you're playing white and you
just try to keep control force you're
going to play defensive and leverage
that into sort of the time advantage I
think that's what he's pretty much doing
because I don't think there's a way to
win d6 anymore but there's a way to keep
it you know keep it there keep it weak
and now what white wants to do is to get
this work into the game somehow build
some more pressure this Knights are good
his work on d1 is good work on f1 could
be approved for sure what's up brother
Josh guys I'm following title Tuesday
I'm only following Magnus right now if
you guys want to follow other games you
can log into the Live interface and take
any game you want there are a lot of
players a lot of good players playing at
the exact same time right now so feel
free to to try that Nakamura is
somewhere in the pack in the chasing
pack and I'm sure he has some exciting
games but here we're watching Magnus
growing this position out he's playing
into two bishops two bishops are
effective in really open positions this
is not really open yet this pawn is
still stuck there aren't a lot of open
paths for the rooks and rook the rook t1
is going to have the next I guess but
black hasn't be able to break free of
this bind yet so the bishops aren't as
effective as they normally would be big
advantage for Magnus so I think he can
just take on he's going to win the spot
yeah and I think it's just going to take
this pawn
otherwise he is named b6 that's even
cleaner so I was thinking c3 work d3
work back and now 94 and you
collectathon
if d5 rook fd1 I'm guessing maybe not oh
he's he's done I'm guessing all the
knows maybe I'll win the guests on with
Destin blacks in trouble here rook takes
or h3h3 is talking the idea of take take
94 check which I'm not sure although
some blocks down to six seconds black is
at six seconds you can't give 40 seconds
having just it's too much
it's a ten-hour tournament and round
turn the rook takes c3 what's wrong with
that looks like a healthy pawn to me and
now it's just about converting maybe
move the King out of the way
in fact blacks not threatening anything
the pawn is pinned there's always work
takes D a check even if d4 even if d4 I
can just move my king out of the way you
can't you're not actually threatening hi
Brooke mm-hm
night c5
very nice block is dead Lobster is going
to pick up a second bond he has his
choice and Carlson is going to move to
three out of three and no bad decisions
yet we haven't seen any comebacks any
points of difficulty for the world
champion I think he's in California and
they just playing some pretty
comfortable chess now that's a third
pawn it's raining bombs block living off
increment but his position is
deteriorating every single move now c4
or king d3 okay anything
Oh neither four checks and thread rook
takes c6 Knight f4 but Magnus play d5
covering it and he doesn't fall for he's
just going to bring his king or
something he's done it one last trick
there let's check that one more time
Knight h5 with the idea of rook takes c6
904 check Vegas saw that coming a mile
away and he's defended it black resigns
Carlsen moves to three out of three
check on the remaining games
what do we have here I think this is
penguin gm1 playing white against Indian
lab that's it I think that's the game
why it's up to pawns so it should be
winning you can't play it for Queen e1
yet it was a queen check maybe that's a
winning winning pawn anything - two
pounds is too much now this is a this is
over so when I see penguin gm1 I am
Andru tank from Minnesota you might be
playing Magnus next round if you can
please this is a Susanna
a bit of an upset based on the ratings
by the point is it's a swiss tournament
so Magnus is going to continue playing
players you know quite a bit lower
greater than end until the field really
thins out but unless white falls for
perpetual this is a pretty
straightforward conversion you just
think okay getting the Queen's off the
board is the hard part if you can't get
the Queen's off the board you slowly
push your pawns I should say it's a bit
harder than first glance because if you
can't trade the Queen's I'm always
threatening Queens you threw your queen
dead kids and you can't push this Punk
too easily so I will take now and by
Kenny six six putting up all resistance
your King e6 what's going on check King
here check and these and you cover the
check so Queen b6 and e6 should win the
game whoa whoa whoa absent works as well
but Queen d6 would cover the diagonal
and then you could just push the pawn so
as I can tell this also works
there's a check here
check-check just a matter of time no
Blitzer the increment is so much
different than bliss without increment
technique is a big big factor in blitz
of increment you get a good position you
have two seconds on the clock
well you're supposed to do well not
you're not so you're not supposed to
flag you're supposed to windows
positions
slowly but surely why it's still
figuring out the winning sequence blocks
and a good job of harassing
I've been ignoring the people on Twitch
I will go check on them now I like to
neglect those people
what's up guys nice to see some good
numbers for title Tuesday I mean you
can't really miss it when magnitudes
playing it's definitely a treat I think
it's really good for chests that the top
layer in the world is a very active
player in plays all the time in the
spotlight that's good for the popularity
of the game and the excited just
everything rivalries entertainment so
why it is now getting close to
checkmating block getting that King up
in there but now he's one of the second
bond and this is a very smooth
conversion oops wait he just blundered
no no no no I can just keep checking I
can I check on z71 never mind I that was
nice you have this geometry here the
King cannot leave the cannot get any
more King g3 Queen e1 oh that's the draw
nicely played nicely played
checking the Queen on the diagonals and
this is going to be a draw I that means
white maybe should have considered not I
mean obviously not taking the pawn not
quite yet but anyways instructive ways
to draw by Indian lad that was a very
long game a few points missed by white
there but okay I mean he's playing on
increment so those fighters move to two
and a half we won't see them playing
mega it's not quite yet why all the
games are done the current standings
there's still dozens of players at least
a dozen players with three out of three
Carlton is the leader there but just to
quickly bring up the standings for you
guys you see Magnus okay they're all
tied in fact he's not even on the list
are you going to sing there are ten
players here ten pairs of three out of
three Carlson is now playing with
Spartacus 1975 oh thank you
like I can I can't read Cyrillic Google
is going to be my friend right now
playing a Ukrainian Grandmaster actually
I do know a little bit Cyrillic quit and
I forgot it Spartak oh I can't let the
heart of Spartak is his actual name so
that's pretty cool Spartacus the soakin
sparta the soakin from ukraine he's
rated 25 31 and he's 42 years old that's
what my quick Google search tells me and
Magnus is playing the Berlin against
them which is a funny choice but he's
just trying to outplay his opponent in a
symmetrical end game in a garage handy
he's just very confident no matter the
position but it's not the normal choice
you playing blitz it's not a common
blitz opening especially when you're
trying to play far away but humble
Magnus here he plays virtually every
single opening and he doesn't get
bothered by the reputation he plays
lions and aren't
excellent or top-notch he's just
confident in his middle games that's his
bread and butter but it's going to be
instructed to see how black tries to be
dynamic in this decision he's got a
little bit less space everything else is
identical I mean I prefer why I play
this variation is why myself
so what's slightly preferable in these
positions and it's considered like no
risk no weak pawns no misplaced pieces
it's very very very very very equal but
we know something is going to gotta get
so let's wait and see in Syria what
Magnus does to try to push this position
some other players on territories david
klein grandmaster from the netherlands a
Cobian at torres agha
who's dr. vitamin who another everyone's
name is in Cyrillic I learned a bit of
Russian when I used to when I used to go
to Russia for chess tournaments on one
of the day Russian girls I forgot all of
it those were my teenage years so I
don't be able to translate some of the
usernames here normally this is you know
if you saw this position and it was too
taut ten players let's say you'd expect
the draw or even pretty soon but we know
Magnus was playing so we know he's going
to play this on and you're going to try
to create some weaknesses but it's funny
you not many players in the world would
be confident trading off all the pieces
putting your pawns on the light squares
but what do you want to do you want to
play d5 and 84 you want to use the D
file I'm still not convinced it's enough
but it's pressure and pressure built up
pressure builds up it's pretty pretty
funny go to Pizza Berlin trade all the
pieces and punish your phone and that's
what it's going to do it's going to get
next e4 he's going to take back like
this and you're going to use the B file
if you rocky to here rookie to Bishop d3
wiki 3 I'm not sure but yeah he's going
to make be to his target that's always
playing for now one good thing is these
problems might be target soon you might
play not well maybe I'll have six yet
because of rookie six but you might try
to play h5 or g6 at some point at some
point the Magnus is trying to get 90 for
the work Hikaru is on two out of three
he's making his comeback Nakamura
storming back guys watch out for him he
wants he wants a piece of Carlson had
that cuz what we want to see as well
Maggie's going to play 94 it's a nice
moment to do it right now take back of
the b-pawn rookie - and then Bishop d3
the Magnus is so good he's going to win
this technically what this is going to
be I'm not going to come commentate on
some business I don't know what it's
planning
he's evaluating different end games I'm
sure of it I'm sure he's evaluating some
design games these bishop and rock n
games but what he's especially
evaluating in the rock endgame is the
rock end game winning after BC for what
the bishops off I don't I mean it
doesn't look winning but he's looking
for positions where he can push there
he's definitely going very deep right
now in terms of evaluating I don't know
what he's thinking
sounds like I'm complimenting him a lot
but I am actually I I'm trying to get
the move
now if you played six I mean I don't
think you see like something really
promising is waiting g6 okay
Bishop takes which it takes g6 let me
take to the bond so after work six if I
work the air and just keep the work out
so what happens after 94 rupee 6 again
but now let's oblige
now let's double-edged also I can play
Bishop b4 cannot quite a bishop here if
work here
rookie what eh-eh-eh X routine check and
if you find any 5 I just move my king
over in the Knights pinned but why it is
is playing good white is holding on so
far this might be the first crack in his
boat that black now 1 the e-file his
Knights ideally placed he has actually
have blacks taken over in the matter of
a couple moves black as an e file his
bishops on d3 his knight ideally placed
on c4 he's got everything going for him
and white is almost and so on so you see
what happened I don't know what just
happened but all of a sudden blacks like
winning almost something just happened
that was ridiculous
dig and rookie to I mean David now lost
now this is just a lost should be a lost
position so Rick II won I can take on b2
I can play rook F 2 but I mean you know
nothing happens all this on you're lost
that's that that's the technical
technical chess
it was pretty disturbing and now he's
preparing to play rugby 3 and he's
winning this pond is winning this pond
his night is on p4 is just a monster
this is the game over
Carlson wins the Berlin and getting
comfortably
there's no perpetual even with his King
on that fit just go ahead and push this
pawn and he's going to set up at nasty
checkmate over here rook check b3 and
rook aid to his mate this game is all
but over and I think him worth studying
or something
the game worth fighting the world
champion showing why he's considered the
best technician in the world
ridiculous ridiculous
he moves to Florida Fork you see he put
all pawns on the wrong color and it paid
off let's check another game um who else
shall we follow us on Lawrence Lawrence
Pete naka Lawrence Trent from England
knocked out he Karim of the first round
slotin and he's at two and a half
thousand three he's playing down which
means mostly plugging somebody over
performing as well and he's trying to
grind out this enemy we got a night in
his bishop but he's got a better punter
I feel Black has double Tom's on the add
file but an active came here and white
spawns on the kingside are all on dark
squares so what happens if I poke you
with bishops III you play a threes and I
poke you again with Bishop b2
I mean Sunday's goddess about magnets
because he's winning the games
effortlessly I mean people are putting
up resistance but he hasn't beaten a
single difficult position he hasn't he
hasn't broken a sweat most likely where
is this night going check okay
his Lawrence messed up as Lawrence would
say might have surged it up a bit you
fudged it I don't think what happens
here so if you take care of liking the
vibe that's what he's afraid of
and now I have a night xf6 and you can't
take be fork is a 95 check I'm going for
the H pawn going for the H fun so blacks
can have two pawns on the Queen side and
why it's going to have an outside this
edge fun running down the board Bishop
should be tonight and after each four
there's Bishop e7 this is lost
it looks like Trent has butchered his
position here
B 4 B 3 a 3 into the pawns push
themselves so nicely here with that
Bishop on f6 and rolek from the
Netherlands we'll move to three and a
half out of four feet a master went very
well
reversing that position you get over
practice you get over press in whoops
got a game going on here
why trying to hold this position but
that extra pawn to e3 keeps this rook
passive he's going to check on e4 your
bring his rook
so he's King to g5 can you find even he
can just king walk down his lot outside
past function when you're just queen
that's all nothing else that's actually
all you do you don't need to memorize
that game you just need to clean your
pond one of the objectives in chess so
the winner of this I think might move to
four to four
how many players on for four yep the
winner was Sergei method all who is an
FM from Russia with Florida for you not
know who is let's take a quick look at
the leaderboard right now four players
with a perfect square who's this tomash
it is to match okay I was a good guess
by me
the 2600 Grandmaster from Hungary you
don't know who Sergei never doubt is no
but clearly clearly very dangerous
probably means he's beaten four
high-rated opponents at least three but
probably for GMS it's got 4gm kills on
his a sort so to speak
but processing and add water Zynga so we
know you know these guys are gonna play
each other cuz it's an even number still
a couple games going the way Magnus is
playing is going to stop them
who is going to stop them a lot of Dutch
guys in this events they all coordinated
today or something I need to get Robin
to playing these everyone else is buying
your tin book flying that all the Dutch
names Roland garrison it's a bit of a
Dutch invasion on the tournament
this while this is a objectively a draw
even material on the same side of the
board block isn't bit of a better
concert trip for the rook at meetings
around the bishop and games are on
somebody would have to blunder
I'm not sure hope putting your pawn on
h4 seems unnecessary putting it on a
dark square each for is there's no
benefit to each form you're not playing
Bishop you sighs no no h4 h4 h4 h4 z
values but what should try to force the
guide but h4 just means you're tied down
to upon what you didn't need to do it
all putting on the wrong color
I would consider trading rooks there
just repeating black might as well trade
books and play wiki five or something
let me check on the neglected twitch
people yep so the world champions on
four to four right now I don't have the
belt no I do not have the belt Danny's
got a belt for checkmate why might not
play well uh I'm commentating but I'm
probably not playing as well because
once I see magnets in the field I'm
going to run away and I'd be pretty cool
to play tennis I have to say so round
five starting here we have four players
on a perfect 404 and the world champion
has blown through the field
he is playing another strong grandmaster
curtain ash vanish from Hungary and he's
going for he was going for slogan goes a
joke Oh piano slow steady and effective
for him no reason for Magnus to take
risk clear unless he chooses to himself
he's he's been doing well and in these
middle games even plain quick in finding
small points of pressure and his
opponents have been succumbing at some
point
but here there is nothing especially at
this is this has played a lot these days
the World Championship feature this
opening the recent World Championship
between Carlson and cardiac and a lot of
toddlers are playing this even lager
kramnik who was a default player for
quite a long time he's recently switched
the e4 he's been plugging these
positions I don't know why the positions
are very symmetrical and they're very
they're very deep they look they look
the same but those subtleties all around
I I could spend a year setting these
positions and probably not fully
understand why certain positions are
better than others
white has a business space advantage
with the pawns on g4 indeed for block
for his party he's got 85 and he found
in he's contesting the center trade-off
with parent pieces he's got peace and
Knights
I mean it seems okay for block to me so
far and he's been quick enough the
prizes that is a great question by shush
this okay so the prizes are 500 for
first 400 per second 250 for third 150
for 400 for fifth and that is in US
dollars not Canadian dollars indicated
dollars really low these days I
definitely recommend Americans for
Americans to visit Canada right now
because game dollars a week but yeah
fifteen hundred dollar prize pool is at
stake but as a segment very beginning
home tech Magnus or ananka are playing
for the prizes I mean that's a good
benefit the prizes are very good but I
think blitz and beating beating rivals
to glory that's available is worth more
at least at least when I play it's
usually just cuz I love glitz we'll see
though maybe maybe they just like taking
the cookie driving they just like taking
our cookies and winning all the
tournaments I wasn't surprised me as
well they're just here to beat on us
working and working grandmasters the
working class the working class
Grandmaster is being punished by magnets
here as you can see double ice will
isolate a bump that is enough to play
for all of a sudden black find
themselves in a locked position
guys position is lost now most likely
negative seven I trade books up internet
on c4i for key five minute but this pawn
structure is already awful already awful
Magnus as once again got into just a
much much better and game double I set
upon the worst sort of double bond
possible and there you have it
this pong balls of this pong balls so
now Magnus will be playing an endgame of
upon up 37 50 seconds and of course he
takes the outside pawn because this is a
weakness anyways give two pawns that you
can capture take the one that is
stronger you can pick up the weaker one
later it's going to be a week later on
but the pick up the one that you might
not be able to get in the future the one
that's time-sensitive so well this is
this is brutal
what's up the pawn lights up on time and
East five is going to fall at some point
Karlsson doing something he does very
well waiting for mistakes from his
opponents he not only beat us like that
he beats top players in the world just
waiting for mistakes he can wait a
hundred moves he can wait 200 moves but
he he plays really well and not this is
the game
I remember reading an interview from
four times
silvia champion dali a ski Aleksandr
borovsky he said I only know two players
in my career who played better in the
sixth hour of play then in the first
hour of play and those players are
Carlson and Karpov coming from a
four-time Soviet champion and that makes
a lot of sense and it's definitely a
very rare attribute he can just prolong
the game and wait for mistakes so in the
context of the Blitz game Carlson third
player who can play better in the 80th
move and in the middle game when he's
fresh he just gets stronger as the game
goes on we're following the board to
between two players on four to four
right now Magnus Carlsen is in clearly
pending this result is at 505 and only
these two players can maintain the pace
I noticed something the audience
mentioned that I have better hair than
magnets this week for those who don't
know magnets has been debuted debuting a
new hairstyle and new glasses he hasn't
worn glasses before as far as I know but
he's also got a new hairstyle sort of
different ways to describe it I'm not
sure if it's intentional but it was a
subject of a lot of social media posts
black here has a big space advantage and
a huge time advantage
I mean g5f for looks crushing this man
on d3 controls everything so this looks
extremely bad for yg5 at 4 looks like a
fantastic I mean this man ID 3 is just
too much too much to deal with their
queen takes these three blocks up upon
the night's hanging but he I'm not even
sure I would have traded Queens in that
position I 92 for kinky rocks Oh
bishop here and rook takes a 7 what
atactic what a tactic by Sergei Nessa
dog
he has rook g7 with the windmill tactic
so the rooks aren't any recovered the
pawn and he's completely fine now he's
not down material he's turned off a lot
of the dangerous pieces and in fact it
might even be blacks King that is a
little bit soft and tender along these
dark squares
this should be five was a nice nice nice
touch and the Toros Etica is rattled
he's spending his time he's just
butchered his position and now he's
facing a very unpleasant task to bishops
for white he's got to get the seventh
ranked this is looking really really
good for Sergei Neff a dog who is a
surprise story a surprise story right
now I mean g4 Kings you to open up
position look at this Bishop over here
it's gorgeous out night at fours using
tactics he wants to play 96 he's
attacking the bishop any starting 96
forking the dishes and the rook to
Isaiah
coming through because I you can't just
let this Bishop stay on d4 it dictates
the whole position
I played Magnus this year for the first
time in my life in the protest week in
the match between the chest brows
against Norway I lost the Magnus but we
won the match so good and bad but it was
a lot of fun so now we're headed into a
bishop end game however this is a this
is a well III is SS you're saying that
you can never capture the pawn because I
control all the squares around it
because otherwise this pong balls and
all of a sudden likes doing well but if
it doesn't falling out so it says those
are attempts to play it
Locke's attempting to play he's hoping
for a move like King g2 where you can
play Bishop g5 check and when the result
in King and pawn and me Pengy so White
has to watch out for that the King can't
go to f1 and it doesn't want to go to g2
Oh
bishop here and maybe addition of three
okay once the play king d5 he wants to
play king leave out King before so no
matter where black does he want to stop
king d5 so Bishop do you want to play
dishes f3
the king if I was threatened
king over good movie you can play King G
toukas efficiency five bishop here I
move my bishop away
I'm always going to cover d5 that's the
goal this is very well played from both
players so far turns egg is really
pushing threatening a lot but twice
credit he is never along and he but she
he's improved his King so now this pawn
never promotes but he never a lot of
King d5 that was well played by those
players in the time scramble problem is
a draw means they fall back to four and
a half out of five which means Carlson
is in clearly this five out of five
let's take a look out and always full
got a game going on that has
implications on the current standings
I believe here this is H and F against
King it's possible to lose this is a
textbook throughout most of the time but
in practical play I think people lose it
maybe more often than the wrong I'm sure
I want it myself
and I didn't even know how to win it I
just wanted by pushing the pawn spot
it's very easy to go wrong here
so whose pleasure
that's entertained playing white against
action tender players around three and a
half out of four so winner will move
into the second place group
let me catch up on the chat I don't know
about you guys but I'm really enjoying
watching magnets just wait for blunders
it's like watching myself five Titan I
remember I played in the pro league I
technically equalizer came close to
equalizing he played quickly he made
some small balls and I just made a
blunder at some point but like it was
rapid chess at some point I'm going to
make a blunder we're getting so we get a
long time like something's got to give
ok now he's lost the pot now this is a
draw easy draw King and pawn and rook
against king and rook when the king is
in the right position this is an easy
draw the king is in time to stop the
pawn so this is an easy draw it's only
when the king is cut off that these are
lost
whereas most to four to five so still in
contention Oh round fives begun let's
quickly put up the standings so 10
rounds determines halfway through world
champion Carlson's in the lead but the
chasing pack has Benjamin buck a
tortoise or turtle
Eduardo after Isaiah and messed up the
name there even though he's a teammate
of mine and Michelangelo was that Luke
aligned edge who drew Carlsen in the
protest week so some strong players
coming up and circle a method of who's
been impressive so far twenty to sixty
feet a and him second place very
impressive so apparently it's a towards
a guy against Carlson across one's going
to the double-team kettle set up here
might be playing c5 he might be playing
94
and it's just going to be a battle of
center squares nope on tension right now
block trying to win the dark squares
keeping this pawn flexible maybe six to
stop this noise from jumping into d5
what might be getting ready to play d4
actually and then we might be
transposing to a sort of morality
structure
hikaru by the way the number two seed in
the tournament after losing in the first
round to Laurence Trent has won four
games in a row he's playing Luka Lennox
who was in second place in the group
with four and half out of five and so he
can find himself right behind Magnus
with a win here
carlene's Lana that's a big match it's a
big match here Magnus is taking a while
to figure out how to proceed here and
he's gone 495 9h to quickly played to
support f/4 Carlson's won the d4 square
so that's that's good for him and I
think he's going to get really six now
maybe f5 and challenge White's pawns
he's got a good night it's got his own
squares it's a sharp sharp position
similar to some closed Sicilians torres
agra by the way up 50 seconds he's
playing instantly they've played before
the world blitz Championships they
played each other and maybe this is part
of his game plan to play very fast
against Magnus maybe he's suffered on
the clock in the past and he's like this
game I'm going to play much quicker so I
remind everybody first prize is $500 the
10 round event and prizes are shared by
in order to share it right now you've
got to catch up the constant was it
clear first with 5 out of 5 I do prefer
blacks position that I'm d4 seems like
the best outpost on the game this night
doesn't have the same freedom blacks got
two very very active bishops don't see
why this
is better or or okay for for wedding
whites just a little bit worse here
he's restricted by you know initiatives
behind this bomb can't really improve
this Bishop over here where this bishops
got a great diagonal in this Bishop is
putting pressure on the center oh that's
not what I thought what happened
so now Magnus was one the bishop there
and I'm liking his position I am liking
his position for sure why hasn't that
anything to wrong though it's still very
balanced but now we have two bishops
against Bishop tonight with still a lot
of tension in the center what are you
going to do about the f5 part of your
magnet so you're going to take here are
you going to take here are you going to
let white take on f5 which would mean is
that pawn f5 on would be very soft think
Magus wants to capture because that 5
would be soft it would be on the light
square between this Bishop can't defend
it on g7 so why it's got some
nice-looking pawns here whereas black
has two bishops some dark square control
the beat file might be playing fish
today 6 next move might be playing queen
bee 4 might be trying to go for am being
more bishops are better we'll have to
see but a pretty tense game its tyr's
egg is a very very good let's player I
think is right around 2700 feet a plaits
so this is a highest-rated opponent that
Magus has played so far it's gone Bishop
8 6 he doesn't want to trade off Bishop
so you want to put pressure on the d3
weakness you might want to assume the C
file soon you might want to trade a
Queen's you might want to put pressure
on hands for they're just going to
counter-attack with those bishops from
far away turns egg is still playing
quickly you still up a little bit of
time but it's starting to dissolve and
rook c5 a nice smooth covering a lot of
these squares and preparing to double
Bishop h3 back and forth affair here
between Carlsen and the Torres Etica
norwegian number one against venezuelan
number one
we few six getting ready to play rook c2
as find there's a double ice move
because it allows black to plant his
Bishop on d5 which is a great diagonal
but I stand seems like Black has more
ways to improve the position of black
white white does not only have five how
does white proceed black my play Bishop
d7 my play with PA it's going to push
the a pawn but white is slowly running
out of moves that that improve his
position definitely said do prefer a
position of consul right now I like the
two bishops I like the V file time
situation prefer white obviously but
there's increment and Magnus is an
excellent ball player excellent blitz
player doesn't Nick mouth lips doesn't
flag so I'm not too concerned there
towards egg is smash a good move removes
though he's up on time maintaining that
she's not blundering he's not he hasn't
made that big mistake yet we have an
entered in endgame and he's doing what
he's supposed to he's going to ask for
Magnus to actually make a mistake I by
pushing it's sort of like an MMA
Anderson Silva one of the greatest
fighters in history he made a career out
of counter counter striking letting his
opponents come to him and make mistakes
and then and then Magnus when he was he
oftens you know what waits for mistakes
but if opponents don't naked then he's
got to push the envelope here and then
blunders might happen
it should be 5f5 still doesn't seem to
work yet this work looks funny this is a
pretty funny formation King is guarded
by both rooks here
negatives has the C file see what
happens
both floor is down to 40 seconds the
Toros Agra is building up an attack now
f5 Queen takes g5 runs into Queen takes
h7 see let's see this is getting really
sharp vision takes news t3 is a threat
though and games are going to save her
block to bishops some of the weak pounds
over here so it turns a Giga trying to
avoid an endgame trying to attack on the
H file maybe he's going to double over
here I'm not sure not sure now the
players I mean now Carlson is up 15
seconds later is etiquette he did an
excellent job of of maintaining the
clock now he's in trouble now he's under
20 seconds and his king is open both
Kings are open but when Kings are open
you got it you usually want to favor the
bishops still he hasn't buggered yet and
a3 trying to win the c3 squared so now
rook c3 is probably going to be the
follow-up so he temporarily sacrificed
his fun now both of these bonds are weak
the c3 is now accessible for the rooks
Carlsen slowly putting some pressure on
on taking the initiative away from white
but a very tense game very very
tentative play from from both players
it's been a very slow build-up Bishop a4
now look c2 as a threat rookie to the
threat because the Queen is pinned
starting to look bad for turns a go Oh
Queen takes a three f5 plays rook takes
d3 Bishop e5 and it's all but over
turns egged down to 10 seconds he
succumbs to the pressure Carlsen wins
let's do a quick replay what just
happened he got the light squared Bishop
off his threatening works
- translator covers we broke up - the
problem is after cleaning 3d trees
hanging and rook c2 is a threat still
after rook F 3 so this pawn falls turns
egged desperately plays on five rook
takes d3 hitting the Queen and the night
and after cleanup for Bishop e5 there
are no spite checks there's nothing to
do
the queen is being hit and then cooked
xg3 next Carlsen comfortably wins again
at least in this position well it's
definitely very tough game for the most
part I'll sing goes to 5 out of 5 let's
check on nakamura gains
lenok nakamura down to pawns here dead
lost position - connected palms is
almost always a win if nakamura lives in
this game he is virtually eliminated
from a potential tearing with Carlson
Oh King before that's a good formation
that's a good formation blocks tied down
a little bit here 9f2
maybe put my knight to d3 so world
champions calls the moodle moves the six
out of six and the chasing pack is
shrinking he's knocking them down one by
one can be six play Oh
95 what did we miss here King at 5 in
king of for looks pretty good didn't it
so Leonard chair has blundered and this
is a draw still that means Nakamura be
one and a half points behind Carlson he
sacrifices night for the two pawns but a
little bit he's letting his time go down
looks like Nakamura letting this time go
down before he captures on D for hours
you might be legging I might be lighting
I'm not sure no he let his time go down
to 0.03 seconds he so Nakamura letting
this time without giving the fans a bit
of a scare making things exciting black
messed up a little bit here I guess
maybe can you put your King here and
maybe go to the side King out for sort
of thing that should be good I assume
this is winning so a missed opportunity
by a local energy and if we take a look
at the current standings so let me put
this game on first this game is between
moskalenko against tang
and looks like they're shuffling king c5
but Ben Benjamin Bach from the
Netherlands is in clear second place at
five 936 he's emerged in queer second
everybody also has drawn or lost
so I mean next row is pairing is
guaranteed Bach against Carlsen Norway
against the Netherlands this is a draw
the reason it's a draw I mean you can't
play for a win his way because after be
forking be about King takes King a
fourth king takes d5 King takes here
this position I have came
hey for you don't want to play for the
win his way
black ends up winning the pot so the
current standings after six rounds
Carlsen 6006 box five-and-a-half out of
six Chandra lennick rolek Spartacus
platy who's Billie Lou some new names
below okay I'm terrible in French names
I'm not going to attempt that off to
think about how to say that but a lot of
terms of five or six but only one player
in second place that's Benjamin Bach
Norway against Netherlands
Nakamura gives out the critical draw
he's he's right now in 12 place with
four and a half of the six question is
well magnetic also get 10 to 10 if
they're a perfect score price is there
is there a perfect score price maybe
there is that would be cool it's very
hard to do that
it was one game going on still I was
waiting for the game started and
realized there's still a game going on
and we have India logic in the newborn
now rook and game where the players have
been repeating for a while there and
move 117 how do you blender I want to
show you guys I'll show you after the
game
I'll show you have to be game what the
trick in the position is but this is the
draw both blocks King can't run away
from the checks and whites King can't
get out of the corner and everything
else is the same same structure but the
trick in the position was and after King
c2 if you decide to be a greedy
Guillermo and take on v6 with okay the
game two starter vacuum any draws it
should have stuck don't need to say
anything more about that but neither
side could make progress
so round seven Carlson has white
leggings block
I believe they played the most recent
world blitz it and rather championship
will you check awesome box
2016 they did they did play at the world
rapid championship Carlson played the
London system and one very comfortably
his wife this time he goes for sort of
Larson set up with b3
so very flexible setup for whites you
can kettle both bishops if you get you
get a lot of pieces on the board you get
it you get a contested middlegame all
the palms all the pieces lots of
possibilities lots to think about you
just play some chess it's not going he's
not striving for that opening edge he
just wants to play play with the pieces
you want style plays opponents bark is
playing very quickly he sped to no time
this is a pretty common opening setup
itself especially in blitz a lot of
Tours like to play this is white you can
kind of pre move right you can make your
moves no matter what when you fianchetto
it doesn't really matter what your
opponents do the usually can't stop it
so let's move that you can and opening
how you can just play 1015 moves right
off the bat and end up with the time
advantage
so h6 maybe giving the bishop an escape
route you know any seven-digit on e6
keep the roof restricted on a 1 it goes
to e 4 okay things are going to sharpen
up now things are going to sharpen up
you want to only take stock of the night
he wants to maybe clear open the D file
no he takes with the rook that's
interesting
running into bishop g6 and maybe
accepting a weekly trip on a very double
edged transaction there because d3 is
sort of soft but on the plus side you
have the e-file
send me open a file your bishop is free
blacks dishes is good this is so now now
the structure has changed Queen c3
threatening checkmate
and also I'm kidding himself from the d3
pawn oh I thought when I went to play so
Queen c3
I keep forgetting if I make a move the
system accepts it because there is the
guess the move feature on chess calm now
where you can make a move before the
players do all right so what has
achieved e4 it's got a bit of a space
advantage clearly here with D 4 and C 4
blocks playing the sort of defensive
formation d6 and c6 often seen in the
Scandinavian defense waiting for white
to push problem is playing past
positions against Carlson is not
recommended you can push he's
comfortable he's patient he's up 20
seconds now he's got the two bishops now
and every single decision in the last
few seems to have been favoring white
two bishops open position he's playing
quicker
the direction of the scheme 96 so the
plot is killing it BOTS can trade off
more pieces I will be critical
you cannot let these bishops just take
over the position but Queen d1 and you
can't take on d5 because the rook is
hanging on yet
I think Magnus is winning I I don't see
well I'm just going to take on u6
attempt without attaining I'm taking on
u6 and the bishops the bishops just
dominate this position again Carlsen
just Out playing Bach in the middle game
getting the two bishops getting the
space breaking through pleasure on the
back line until until something now
something profitable came and here it is
here it is this looks really really
really I mean I start looking looking
for tactics rook lifts you start
considering to take and take thing ideas
like this come to mind you can also move
your book back all these options are
very tempting work back and you've done
it he's out 30 seconds he's felt fun
quickly but it's an open position with
two amazing bishops or and the Queen is
it effective the rooks are doubled on a
target everything is good here
I definitely think this is winning for
for Carlsen clock might play Queen g5
threatening to take on g3 because the
pawn is pinned and this complete
community just kingi to simple effective
still pinned rook takes a looking worse
and worse because Bach is tanking on the
clock so he gets out of the pen the
Moose's work over but now I'm thinking
about Queen c2 I just realized that runs
into Knight takes d5 and there's a
discover Netta for checks we play this
rook c5 first rough
Bock is hanging on for dear life here
Carlson's trying to try to make this
work at someone not yet you gotta move
the Queen somewhere just figure out
where do I move the Queen
maybe Queen to see one and then take on
you six maybe Bishop h5 a few options
here to think about taking sometimes
that definitely means he's looking for
tactics don't that's not the booth place
Queen c1 and he is going to take care
pretty sure what else you have to move
your queen oh he can move the Queen at 4
but then the d5 pawn and Jane Carlson
getting on Tonya he does not find the
knockout move Magnus Carlsen getting
into serious time pressure for he's
behind on the clock with less than 30
seconds and nay takes d5 now why can't
you take topology council play Bishop d6
pinning the rook couple nice options
this should be five rook takes d5 lock
up upon Benjamin Bach up a pawn and has
some decent chances here to hold to win
we're not sure that she could respond
now and hanging which restores material
equality but I don't think he's in any
it is not many issues here Queen c2
threatening Queen f2 and the bishop
bishop here may be Queen e2 Queen e2
runs into Queen at 500 tactics tactics
around the block is up a pawn and
they're at a time scramble here Benjamin
Bach is playing for to result a winner
of dries up upon a clear plan on the
Queen side here we're seeing the world
champion incident he couldn't find a way
to use the bishops to to break through
and now he is going to have to defend an
endgame
so Queen here I'm expecting rook b8 o
Bach gives up the material I think he's
just headed for a draw goat takes a
three
and Queen f3 King G - he's going to go
for the draw but not a bad result at
least we see that you can draw blood
from the world champion here he
struggled in that portion of the game Oh
magnets plan for when keeping the
Queen's on the board and he sees a weak
pawn he's going for this equal nature
he's going to play this on Carson's
going to play this on he's piling on the
pressure playing really fast all of a
sudden now and he's got a little bit of
a better side of his work at a game due
to this weak pawn likely a draw
however if anybody can win it's white
it's Magnus Carlsen he's got some sort
of idea here to play for the win
I've actually seen negative we lose
positions before and blitz so don't be
surprised if you something happens don't
be surprised if something happens
buck was up upon and he really did not
come come out of that well she's he's
out the pond of clear pond it now he's
just in a rocking game with a worse
position and now the king has cut off so
Magnus cutting off his King maybe he
wants to at some point target g7 king up
for making some progress though making a
little bit of progress still is raw
still is wrong but if buckets long times
blunders can happen like if you trade
off the rooks some of these pauline
games could be winning for white finally
pushes okay I mean I think it's going to
be a broad Baca's buck is no slouch but
he's going to have to prove a bit more
before
Magnus agrees to something but I mean he
was up the clear pond in an engine so he
could have pushed much better Magnus now
as potential for an outside pawn Oh
rook check his King has cut off if his
King wasn't cut off you have really good
chances here so he's making some some
progress although still a draw King has
cut off you can't really witness with
the king cut off unfortunately
so there are no video right now Karlsson
playing in second place
Benjamin block from the Netherlands to
reckon game even material and he finally
goes for f7 so rook here rook c5 check
is given and they're going to repeat I
believe nope
going for this box playing were caged
for a nice nice moves just cutting the
King off and it Carlsen offers a draw
Carlson has offered a draw he he says
you know you played well enough to
defended you shown your defense how you
deserve a job but a pretty back and
forth affair here
Carlson finally gives up half the point
but he's still in clear first a big
result for Benjamin Bach drawing the
world champion with black Benjamin Bloch
also beat Hikaru Nakamura I believe in
October at the Isle of Man Turman so
he's had some top-notch results against
top-10 players so the current standings
right now are Carlsen clear for six and
a half out of seven and three melt three
rounds to go we have Bach with six out
of seven oh I have to pronounce his name
I need to improve my French delay Alou
has six out of seven
davell I am below the lachen from France
that's my attempt
he's on six out of seven and he's going
to play Bengals probably so I better
learn how to pronounce his name in the
chasing pack starting from fourth we
have Indian law Chandra Lana's Erlich
Spartak Sam seven who else Hikaru
we got knock over here at Tara's I got
moskalenko many players but unless
Magnus gives up another house polymer
point they can't really catch up to him
so let's get back to the game and the
game is between look at that Queen Age 5
Queen h5 is being played this is called
the pastor's opening for those who don't
know even on our YouTube channel we
actually have a video on this Queen h5
the pastor attack it's a lot of people
call this you just go for checkmate in
four moves so trolling or being serious
I'm not sure I'll let you guys decide
but it it's it's a tricky line we've
actually covered it on the channel that
is the first time this event Magnus
Carlsen has been faced with the
checkmate threat from the opening don't
think you see that every day and White
has spent in no time I believe he's by
this opening many times in the past he
seems very comfortable he's playing he's
playing the theoretical moves this is
still theory and he's up thirty Seconds
we'll see if it pays off once again the
first checkmate thread on Carlsen right
from the opening they should see four
you know that's sort of the pre move
maybe the pre move attack to of your
opponent pre moves they get made it you
know keeps people on it in bullet that
might actually work in bullet you play
d4 they play e5 you play Bishop c4 they
play let's say 96 and you play Queen f3
or queen is five now if they pre move
Knight f6 end up getting checkmated so
in bullet I've seen people lose like
that but in blitz against Magnus not so
easy
hey even if you lose you're known as the
guy who went for the form of checkmate
against Magnus
by the way Jakarta Nakamura supply this
opening and classical game as well so
it's not as obscure as it may seem so
Magnus has two bishops opposite side
Kaplan he's looking into a
counter-attack on the queenside white
for his part wants to play maybe 493 and
h5 and breakthrough on the h-bomb d5 oh
I like this b5 CB v + g5 things are
really sharpening up here onboard one
but this is a very pace I mean this is a
very double-edged position this is
definitely can go wrong with either
color many misses are going to have to
handle this with extreme care and I mean
he's playing principle is just kind of
attacking he asked it because otherwise
White will get grabbed the initiative
very quickly
so after bc 6 d4 Knight a4 maybe what's
going on here what is going on so if you
take here before i'm much of d4 is a
move a lot you know maybe you take care
if you take your Knight takes e4 he to
things that's the idea okay so that's
what what's thinking about if you take
on c6 I take on you for and your knight
is under attack and you have to defend
it to and remember with two bishops open
positions or what you want to strive for
some Magnus is feeling very confident
that if you can have this sort of open
position open battle that it's bishops
will come out ahead looking like a nice
Center over here looking like a nice
Center 94 we jump to c5 wants to get rid
of those bishops ASAP
can you cure I play 95 and I won winning
your Bishop there world champion Carlson
she's got a 1/2 point lead on the field
right now so still everything to play
for
and another big game this round is
Benjamin book again see Cara Nakamura
knocking rose up a minute box King and
sort of exposed but it is an endgame
material even white even had the outside
fastball
anything could happen here so her
keeping an eye out on that because
Benjamin block is in second place and he
is one of the few people if you guys
left who could realistically surpass
Magnus or catch up Tim Magnus here went
for queen of e5 Queen takes d5 at rook
c8 and he says that this end game is
good for black so Magnus is saying that
this is a good ending for black what do
you guys think
rook the three blocks got some really
ugly double e pawns to the benefit of
those W funds you can double on the F
file this pawn is sort of soft but
called pawns are on the wrong color for
black in some ways but the F file might
be weak so I think Magnus is planning a
double now found by Bishop h6 maybe b4
first maybe b4 and in five okay he does
this cross things are going to double on
the F I'll keep these rooks passive on
d3 and f1 we're going to see a technical
display here whether it it pays off I'm
not sure but Magnus wants to go into
this nd he's got his own weaknesses
though that's something we haven't seen
too much he got his own weaknesses over
here and c3 I mean you can find yourself
lost in somebody that means that the
material even and if someone is black
has a worse pawn structure Seagal is
going to have to come up with something
here
because this is the endgame he might
even find himself on the white side up
sometimes playing against this and that
but piling on some some decent pressure
here on the C file still looking for a
breakthrough I agree with this decision
you don't want to trade you need to
defend D for a for okay and you think
can happen here is opponent playing it
very well even on the clock and fighting
and fighting hard pretty sure his
opponent is a teenage French
international master move e5
so now decisions have to be made we got
some real tension in the center I don't
think you can take on d4 because I
booked d7 and after Bishop c3 I have b4
and you're going to lose a piece so
tactics are in favor of white and a line
but maybe you should just take your
first take on any form then maybe try to
go for something like that I'm not sure
some calculation is taking a bit too
much time here though took 20 seconds on
that you had to play the quicker can't
get this long time with some big
decisions to be made now he's going for
because there's no key for but after
here
Bishop c3 Knight at for rook d2y up a
pawn here
there's no before he calculated he's
like I'm up upon rooks t2 now doesn't
mean it's a great pun this is weak this
is weak King was vulnerable everything
is pinned but upon Oh night here so now
92 a 92 white offers a draw Y is now
offered to draw out the pond he wants to
see what Magnus does I like that draw
for long time trying to confuse your
opponent plus you're off the pond
temporarily if you're going to draw the
houses last opportunity to do it up upon
so now we're playing an endgame even
material this is weak and this is weak
so who's going to arrive first
maybe objectively this is a draw for the
players a long time so somebody might
arrive first whose
who's going to do so I'm not sure magnet
has more active king but the a pawn also
runs pretty quickly I mean King up King
up push we might be headed to a draw
here
Magnus draws that human bak has a
realistic chance of catching up to world
Trinity Magnus Carlsen and making this a
very close race super get 5 push push
push push to the bottom Oh 91 91 and you
cannot stop this from cleaning even the
white cap is on Queen Carlson is going
to have the Queen first and he's going
to have the first chance to throw checks
as opponent Magnus Carlsen once again
emerges ahead in an endgame he
calculated us out beautifully
he is one move ahead and that's all it
takes the check mate with a queen rook
in the knight on the board
Queen check here I assume this is
winning he's gonna have to find it if he
does check check everything looks pretty
good yeah we have a checkmate
approaching guys queen up to rook e1
Queen c2 is made queen d3 Queen c2
that's checkmate Carlsen moves to seven
and a half of the day a really really
nice sequence blow on time he's the one
who found the most precise moves and he
was faster maybe black I mean maybe wife
had to consider sacrificing quickly for
the spawn and then trying to win blocks
rook for his a bomb maybe with g1 was
the move maybe what you want I'm not
sure the calculation but with low time
Carlson's instincts held up in this game
Bach and Hikaru drew so that means
current standings
bring them up Carlos needs seven hats
out of eight Oh bull point lead on the
field this is the biggest lead she's had
and the chasing pack is a full point
behind
so pretty much magnus carlsen now has to
lose in order for him to relinquish the
lead and relinquish control this event
but the way he's been playing he was a
bit iffy against bug bidding bility in
this game but he's been pretty clutch
o'clock Simon going down
he's his nerves have had held up high
chandra might be a likely pairing sam-7
we might be seeing you know USA against
Norway in round nine one of the teenage
grandmasters one of the many that the
u.s. now boasts one game remaining
before we get into round night there are
two rounds remaining it's a 10 round
event and here we go round 9 magnus
carlsen is Akshay Chandra newly minted
grandmaster residing in st. Louis cross
and open double d4 and he goes for his
London system one of his favorite setups
to ship out for Knight f3 is going to go
III see 392 this is so fashionable these
days if you are a player who plays block
you might as well booked up against
London because it occurs so much in
practice
[Music]
Shandra blitzing Ultimo's definitely
have some preparation here do too I mean
he's an active German player I'm sure
he's faced this many times and he is
opted for a pretty aggressive set up
here with Queen b6 putting pressure on
white wants to win this Bishop h6 maybes
going to move in any way they play a six
and try to target this b2 upon Carlsen
if you win this Magnus Carlsen windows
can be guarantees himself at least a tie
for first he's got a full point lead
with only two rounds or many
but so far the position is down just
like it normally is when it's running
system it's it's a matter of preference
but objectively blacks normally done
anything to wrong and my name is quickly
plays ninety five trying to provoke the
shitakes b-58 xp5 and he wants a mini
victory claiming the a file with action
Chandra seventeen or eighteen years old
a lot of young magnets display that
Magnus has been playing a lot of young
players this event younger than him he
was becoming a veteran which is
disconcerning for you guys like me I'm
going to feel like the veteran pretty
soon as well so he takes the Queen
though he doesn't try to win the hey
thought I think he was afraid of I'm not
going to analyze much but I think he's
afraid of maybe this pawn on d5 becoming
weak but still a pretty symmetrical
position and I think Magnus is adopting
a strategy this game of just waiting
waiting for a mistake
White's got a little bit more space but
two pieces I've been treated off she's
got no clear edge on any side of the
board he's got a nice night here but it
can be triggered off at some point I'm
attracted to the move Knight at five
ninety six then IG six looks very
effective
and a six okay well that is a confession
maybe it won't happen action but now now
I've seen costume play the structure
before this controls these coupons I see
him enter a better in game there's a
game he played recently where he won a
game solely because he got a bottom 85 I
recall vividly from the world blitz and
rapid championships he went into a
rockin game and he claimed an edge due
to have him spawn 85 controlling two
bonds and and he ended up with the
plugin engine so I know it I seen this
before this is deja vu he's going to use
this pawn he's going to take and play b3
now and probably recycle another night
on to c5 g3 yes and he's going to put
some pressure on b7 white is now
starting to clean a bit of an edge I've
seen him win a game like this before I
really have so I know magnitudes in his
comfort zone right now he's getting that
night to c5 he's protecting a five he's
bringing this rook over to be one this
is starting to look really good for
white because he's going to get free
pressure on b7 when you give Magnus free
pressure he takes advantage of that a5
fun really fixing these pawns on the
queenside freezing them up and allowing
white to play the game so maybe rook to
d1 or 95 rook e1 this is very very very
annoying
night night here he wants to play Knight
d5 and jam the B file but again we get
into an endgame and a lot of these rare
kind of games are gonna be better for
white because in effect white will be
playing up a bond because a5 controls
these two so in the center let's say
this Knight moves out of the way we
trade off some pieces White has the
potential for passed pawn the center
wears black it's going to have to work
very hard to somehow get something going
on a queen side Carstens definitely has
this position a similar position before
playing for the endgame advantage just
think about this as a potential for
passed pawn for life
this controls both of these guys so
Magnus has the pull here and he's up a
full 60 seconds I went for crawls and
guarantees at least a tie for first so
Brooks is having getting ready to
challenge the C file Magnus is okay
let's go for the endgame 93 and I expect
trades I might even have everything rid
off as of Queen and night we'll see but
white can definitely manage this night
on c5 then I can always go back to c5
putting pressure on these bonds this a5
phone is not being targeted much at all
Magnus is going to go for and give this
is getting better and better
I can say for sure hardly there's hardly
anybody on earth who can go toe-to-toe
with Magnus in an end game where the
slider works like holding those two
those very few players who can keep up
the quality of those that Yugi puts out
his output and endgame is off the charts
nothing happens and then something's
lost so g4 chatter down to 20 seconds he
does know what to do if things get rated
off-white is it going to push up on at
some point gonna get his 19 v b7 is
really weak white house control over the
C file and you cannot trade Queen c7 I
take and I play 95 and I win the b7 pawn
Chandra really in a desperate situation
here why is he taking so much time
people are wondering because E is
uncomfortable this is actually an
extremely unpleasant position despite
the material equality white is full
control over almost every aspect of the
board the Queen side the center starting
to invade maybe g3 King G - maybe 93 95
slow moves by Chandler down to 9 seconds
and still figuring out how to hold this
94 might even be a move here maybe not I
want 94-96 Queen C five wins material
that's just the cheapo dog Magnus is now
looking for a knockout blow
I think you might end up going for
three actually okay 97 meaning the Queen
asked us be close by
ninety-seven sorry 95 95 is maybe moved
maybe not 95 king of seven holds
constant getting dangerously close to
something but at the same time is not a
spin you've got to be little bit careful
and be a little bit careful here
actually I don't like what he's done I
do not like what Carlson is down here
because that night is pinned that night
is pinned and now King g8 is a threat no
it's not because of Knight takes f6
kinian Knight takes f6 and night falls
over here oh now there may be g5 or this
bond is weak okay Carlson now once again
putting on a lot of pressure you can
play your knight takes f6 Carlson is now
in a winning cleanup on endgame black
just couldn't hold the position long
time that's another pawn you can just
trade Queens if you want Queen check and
Queen c5 or Queen g5 game over Magnus
Carlsen wins again made it look very
easy
he had no risk he was pushing and there
you go eight and a half of the ninth
but this point of a5 I'm telling you
these end games are very unpleasant he's
won if you like this before that's what
he does best slow steady pressure and
very little risk full control scroll
somos de nada of nine let's move the
board to let's watch Akkar oh I almost
forgot about him not because he's been
playing that badly but Magnus has not
really given up any points and cacao has
he lost in the first round and he gave
up two draws not his best result but it
is a very strong field they should see a
by NACA and now he's going to win this
pawn and this one we got a bishop it
gained a bishop and two pounds against
Knight because this thing's gonna have
to move and he car was going to go into
what looks like look at the time guys
two minutes the 14 seconds that's brutal
you can just take you can just take the
knight Knapp Kadir has two minutes he is
torturing his opponent playing with him
he can just take the net itself
stalemate not good and he's going to
take with the pawn and he's going to
push the pawn put his bishop back he
wins
but he's fighting for third he's
fighting for second she's not fighting
for first let's bring up the current
standings Carlson inhabit a night Sam
seven seven and a half the only one in
second place four players in third Luca
lenok he Cara Nakamura Aleksandr
moskalenko and 43 is a low-key show from
Argentina
those guys cannot catch Magnus so it's
going to be seven against Carlsen round
ten seventh the only one who can stop
crossing from cleaning up
let's check out some players we haven't
seen before let's check out this game
two national masters dueling it out
playing down to Queens this is the sort
of stuff you big mainly see on the lower
boards or they're playing down to Queens
things like that they're just fighting
it out they're just enjoying blitz let's
take a break from that crazy high-level
chess call since playing and just
appreciate the lone King here fighting
against the world fighting against two
ponds and two queens let's appreciate
the lower boards of the event big mac
2500 from spain fighting on for dear
life here deciding not to resign he
wants to go down go down leaving in for
Queens this is what happens on the lower
boards they're just dueling it out King
and games to Queens to pawns
the struggle is real and he offers a
draw he offers a draw I mean this is the
sort of stuff you know chess is
difficult until you get to the top where
it's you know comfortable events you
faced look at that he's fighting on
offering the draw running the King
around this is this is what it's all
about here we got Magnus Carlsen playing
some clean chests and we got these guys
embodying the hustlers scared in chess
you know is making moves torturing us a
little bit giving us a break from from
Magnus and is extremely accurate chess
this is like chess club it's like Fight
Club over here that's just pushing the
pieces these guys are just having fun
playing chess they're just enjoying it
can't fault the one guy likes playing
with this game along I'll explain with
the Queen's it's a free world out there
on the chess board
look at that so nice trolling to give us
a break these players are just giving us
a break and he offers another draw three
draw offers by Big Mac 2500 they're on
move 107 going hard over here going hard
and you finally pushes that pawn to stop
the 50 move rule so we can go
theoretically I think 150 more moves
because what's one two three pawn moves
you move your pawn before move 50 so
we've got 150 more moves to go this is
the sorta Saul about the lone King
against the world maybe a bit of a
metaphor you know take Mac 2500 gets one
random accessories from Fiji I'm not
sure that's true maybe there's not a lot
of things to do in Fiji
so he he's enjoying his Queens
you guys are going for about 250 moves I
believe that's the goal and they're
allowed to do it that's the thing that's
that's it so let's just sit back relax
grab a drink we still got another game
of magnets remaining I'll say one thing
though they these guys might actually
they're not following us they might be
trolling Magnus think about that Magnus
has to wait for these games to finish
before he can win the tournament it's
like if I was playing tennis and Roger
Federer has to wait for me to finish
playing with them on and we like you
know it's like think about that think
about that it's like me playing football
with my buddies and Nancy has to wait
for us before you can kick it oh that's
pretty funny that's a good way to flow
it's very effective actually this is
something to learn from
think about me shooting some hoops and
like LeBron has to wait for me to make a
basket I may take a long time so there
are move 142 and this is all legal guys
they still got a good 120 moves to go
and the whole tournament is waiting I'm
enjoying it though well I'm enjoying I
need to grab the drink that's why I'll
be go have a drink here bar
no I don't I'll actually stay commentate
I'll stay until the very end she Carlos
said in the chat is this a joke we're
getting players requesting for them to
ban Benjamin Bloch is asking chess comm
to ban these players you're starting to
see some protests protests are happening
I wouldn't be surprised to see a
battalion of grandmasters with signs
getting ready to March so the protests
are starting out in the riots look at
that chaos is about to it's good anarchy
anarchy that's it's going to make the
tournament more exciting you might see
some people withdraw from the tournament
in protest but they are allowed to do
that guys the 50 move rule you need to
push a pond within that 50 move frame so
if I move it to push that pond and Big
Mac wins by resignation the Big Mac is
playing black a big upset the King beats
the world black wins Big Mac beats one
random the King beats two queens and two
pawns that's the underground that's it a
underdog story of the year I mean who
cares about born one Sevilla and Carlsen
the King the king is worth something
guys you need to use your king and chess
that's the lesson of the day
don't neglect your King don't always
protect it
Kings can garden and take pause and and
do things as well the king wins so the
game concludes and Big Mac the Spanish
king wins against two queens and two
pawns and so now we're back to board 1
round 10 final round to go Magnus
Carlsen let me put up the standings for
y'all one sec Carlson's has a full point
the only way for him to not win here
first is to lose his plane Sam's Debian
that's the only match that is for first
place 7 house white and you have to win
in order to catch Carlsen here we go
here we go and Magnus played what open D
play he played the Berlin draw secures
first place for him but if he wins this
1910 is a month to score against at his
rating he's getting very close to 3,000
bucks 2,000 votes is ridiculous on chess
calm for prospective nacos 2866 and 100
points 150 points is a big gap
Savion gives up the bishop there so now
we have a crippled pawn structure over
here not that crippled by [ __ ] the
two bishops against two nice so it is
going to be dynamic it looks like white
is threatening in some lines actually no
you can't play metaphor yet because it
before but it's two bishops again
tonight Carlson has a bit of a worse
pawn structure but this looks good for
black it looks like the two bishops give
potential to open up at some point as
5g5 c5 I don't know these pawns are all
very loose I like white I like blacks
position rookie three okay so sevilla
might be preparing to play 92-93 and
transferring this man over to the king
side protecting me for and opening up
his rook on the C file got a win here
Scott Irwin here if he wants to stop
Magnus but if he draws he guarantees
himself at least a share of second b5
hoping that mag mistakes and blunders
because of 95 95 was the cheeky threat
said via a draw for 7 ensures the decent
cash prize a win is all the glories
beating Carlson I would you know beating
Carlson is worth way more in my opinion
but that's way easier said than done
especially the position here that I
think is totally fine for black blacks
are two bishops and is slowly building a
pressure on the center pumps there is a
prize pool first place is $500 second is
400 third is 250 fourth is 150 and fifth
is 100 so top 5 get a prize and if you
tie for top 5 prize you share it with
the other people so tie breaks aren't
the factor so if 7 wins he ties refers
with Magnus and they essentially split
first and second $90 which equates to
450
position is opening up here but you see
Carlson up 20 seconds and I mean it's an
open position that should favor the
bishops so no matter what's really going
on it's not the strategical style of
what normally wants when you play with
the Knights against the bishop when you
play against double bonds you don't want
those songs to undle so Carlton's
definitely doing good in this position I
expect him to just double rooks and try
to pile on the pressure here I mean you
may be thinking about can I just take on
d4 again a draw in true square first the
wind is just a masterful performance and
a lost ball I tell you then you want to
avoid so he's not going to take extreme
risk I suspect it's been a very clean
event he has never been in the last
position so far thus far role champion
magnus carlsen making an appearance on
chest coms monthly title tuesday men
remember this is the first Tuesday of
every month
too strong event cash prizes and
interesting things happen as we see
anything happens you know this is this
is where a bunch of title testers come
in a fight so I'm not being pretty
exciting so now we have an end game here
and Magnus is on better side of it we've
heard that before
he's got the big shot he's got targets
he's got targets here here here and now
he's going to target on a three because
I that's on the same color as his Bishop
so Carlson is increasing his advantage
increasing his time advantage and this
is looking worse and worse check and
maybe he'll recycle this rook to e8 to
be eight and to be three
it should be six rooks III anyways the
pawns are favorable for the current
bounce which was favorable for black
what's threatening work c4 here to pick
up the a four pawns maybe Ricky a trick
aid is called for I'm not sure you can
still play rugby 3 but that pawn will
fall after trade everything would be to
get depends across someone's he can draw
this position on demand but in order for
him to win you'll have to find a little
something extra so he plays d5 provoking
Zambian to play e5 putting more pawns on
the dark squares that's what that's what
Carlsen once d5 also stops white from
playing rook c4 that looks like a class
move to me and maybe he'll swing the
rook around there there there there
there a long journey but make some sense
oh he goes for a sixth instead trying to
immediately put some pressure on the
center what his life is after ef5 the
db5 Crossan would be able to play c5 and
get oh that a blunder Bishop a5 Bishop
a5 Bishop a5 by Carlsen there should be
five wins in exchange Magnus Carlsen
here has a win he finds it a rook is
going to fall and there we go
the gut the guide the world champion is
going to move to nine half of then you
go wipe out the field today that's the
story of the event
his opponents I've been making blunders
he's up in exchange here there's a local
counterplay but we're talking with
Magnus he is up to 15 seconds he's up a
rock an exchange I mean he's going to
convert this most likely so there we go
now it's going to be a battle for second
place
I expect maybe the rook f6 Knight here
rook here and he's going to play h5 and
that's going to be game over the Knight
has to move there's going to be a
resignation from sam sevilla magnus
carlsen takes the main title tuesday
with outstanding 9 in hospitals and even
as a world champion even as as maybe the
best best looks player best speech a
star in the world i think that's a fair
claim for him
nine and half nine a half of ten is
higher than his expected score nine out
of ten is like you know above the 3,000
performance it's just ridiculous push
the pawn play review one King cut off
seven is playing on might as well you're
[ __ ] world champion but the result is
not in doubt and the resignation is
there there we go so now it's the battle
for second place Hikaru has climbed his
way back to second to look at the
current standings guys Constantine has
clear first got a couple percent eight
Bristol games ongoing so let's quickly
rush over see who rounds out the podium
we've got a game right here between Luca
lennick playing block against I think
this is Moi's Inc oh yes several more
ski is Alexander Machine Co from Ukraine
to very strong grandmasters here and
black flags here is fork and any Flags
I'm not sure that was forced he has
would be won in this position although
that's a really bad position so language
gets knocked out here when would have
put him in the group a second for second
place
so my Gingka wins this game let me and
we are all Benjamin Bach yes
although these guys can't catch no these
guys have six and a half I think that's
clear then he Cara Nakamura and belay
loop tie for second and third with a
turret n- speed everybody so badly that
hitted attend gets you a very very
decent prize because he knocked everyone
down he only gave up one draw that was
the Benjamin Bach and even back here is
now winning in Spartak a great result
for the Dutchman who drew Hikaru and be
quite a few grandmasters on roots
a seven half of the tenth performance
which should net him a tie for fourth
not a big five but he actually played a
roamer field and a lot of players could
he start off strong so doc wins we're
starting to see the final tally over
here let's bring it up one more time
Carles ten nine and half of the 10 lay
low
eight out of ten Ricardo ate it at ten
five players on seven half so we're
going to share fourth and fifth fourth
is 155th is 100 so five players $250
they each get $50 seven half under ten
that's Sam seven Benjamin buck
moskalenko newborn now several more ski
who's got that 50 and that rounds out
the prizes let's see if there's a few
more games left Oh Big Mac is playing
the lone King was playing guys oh no we
got the legendary Spanish King here
playing with the King once again Big Mac
is playing with the King against two
queens is he going to draw no he goes
down here against helgi olufsen the
Icelandic Grandmaster finishing him
ruthlessly with the two queens against
King but we're seeing we're seeing this
guy often finding himself down to Queens
Big Mac story of the event as well but
anyways that was may dog sensing title
Tuesday here on chess calm very strong
event very exciting lots of different
games going on at once
we'll leave the standings on the board
but I hope you guys enjoyed the
tournament I absolutely did it's a
really treasure really a treat to see
Magnus playing at a high level like when
Magnus is informed it's pretty
ridiculous
I thought we saw some incredibly
consistent strong chess from him today
some some really high caliber shows more
than his usual which is already you know
the best in the world but it was
exceptional today a very strong event
the next one is next month but hold on
tomorrow is the first match in the speed
chess champion
she car was playing and I'm going to
play the promo that gives you all the
details so stay for this
17th speed Chess Championship brings
together 16 of the world's strongest
most superhuman chess players among them
you'll find none other than former
Women's World Chess Champion grand
master ho ye farm the reigning US chess
champion Grandmaster Weslaco World Chess
Championship title challenger
grandmaster sergey karaoke the most
feared man in bullet chess today
grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura and of
course the grandmaster blitz battle
championship winner and reigning World
Chess Champion magnus hull don't miss a
single moment of the action as me delete
chess players battle it out for the
better part of a fifty thousand dollar
prize fund the action kicks off on may
3rd when the Cara Nakamura takes on the
first qualified Challenger with Magnus
Carlsen playing his first match of
October 5th all the action will be
brought to you on chess comm / TV
twitch.tv slash chest or one of our
numerous foreign language portals fans
can find coverage in Russian French
Portuguese Spanish and many more go to
Capcom TV to vote a full schedule of
events for the 2017 speed chess
championship fill out a bracket for a
chance to win big prizes and don't miss
a single moment as we show you the
world's best chess players in this
thrilling eSports event will see you on
chess calm
and there you have it guys speed Chess
Championships it starts tomorrow if you
want to know about the programming chess
comm offers go to www.hsn slash forward
slash TV and there's a schedule there
and so tomorrow we have Hikaru Nakamura
playing I believe is playing Sergey
gregorian's and that is at 10:00 a.m.
Pacific 1:00 p.m. Eastern
it generally runs three hours and Danny
wrench and Anna Rudolph will be the
commentators so don't miss that Nakamura
against her Guardians death match speed
Chess Championships tomorrow that's
round one of this elimination event and
that's going to kick off a very busy
year programming and high-level blitz
why should you have the protest view but
that's going to kick off this year's
speech Chess Championships so this was
title Tuesday May 2017
I'm grandmaster accountant thank you for
joining me for two and a half hours of
blitz chess I hope you guys enjoyed it
and I'll see you next month for more
well I guess
[Music]